>> Jeff: BLUE JACKETS WEARING
THEIR ALTERNATE JERSEYS STICK
SEASON -- OR FIRST GOAL
OF THE SEASON, EXCUSE ME EXCEED
EXPECTATIONS IN THE FIRST MONTH.
>> Jody: YEAH THEY HAVE AND THEY
IT'S KEPT IN,JENNER, RIGHT BACK
TO OLIVER, NYQUIST TRY YEAR
AND DOES GREAT THINGS.
>> Jeff: CENTERING PASS KNOCKED
OFF INTO FRONT.
KIND OF BREAK DOW THE WINGS
WILL WALK IT OUT.
HRONEK LOOKING FOR THE RETURN
FEED. -- YOU CAN SEE IT
GOES RIGHT THROUGH HIMERE.
WINS THE DRAW.
BJORKSTRAND.
AWAY.
JENNER, THIRD ATTEMPT.
DOWN IS GREISS ANDBJORKSTRAND C
SILLINGER E.
WERENSKI.
THERE'S  JENNER.KNOW WHAT?
YOU CAN DO WHAT YOU WANT. AHEAD.
AND REBOUNDING DEFEFE LED 2-0,
IT
>> Jody: THAT WAS A BEAUTIFUL
PLAY, AND HE COMES
INCLUDES AN EXCLUSIVEFEED.
HERE'S TEXIER WITH A HIGH WEREN
GAGNER, THE WINGS BACK AT FULL
STRENGTH JACKETS DON'T GET A
BANKS IT OFF THE BOARDS, ELVIS
COMES OUT OF THE NET TO PLAY.HE.
ZACH FROM CENTER OFF A LEG.
ON THE TURNOVERMBUS WILL TRY AG
VORACEK, HERE'S CHINAKHOV ON A
HAS TO STAY WITH IT AND WHAT AN
IMPRESSIVE PLA
SHOT THERE BY BJORKSTRAND NO
STICK, GUS SAYS TAKE THIS,IN TH,